In the beginning there was nothing.
So the world was grey and lifeless.
But then there was the First Flame,
which brought warmth, life and light.
But these things cannot exist alone,
so there was also the Disparity.
Cold, death and dark.
Humans were born from the Dark,
but we are drawn toward the Light.
We are warmed by fire, but this fire we can not touch.
For those whose fascination with fire persists
learn to hold it in their own hand.
Pyromancy is born from the saturation of fire.
But you must remember one thing.
"Always fear the flame,
lest you be devoured by it, and lose yourself."
"I would hate to see that happen again…"
It is the nature of fire to fade, until only dark remains.
But what if another flame was borned?
It could be a replica of the first to ward off the Darkness.
The Witch of Izalith was one of lord Gwyn's last hopes.
If she could replicate the First Flame
then the gods power would never fade.
It would have been better
if she never tried.
"Hmm… I have a favour to ask.
My mother...
... the Witch of Izalith...
...was one of the primeval Lords.
Her power came from the soul that she found near the First Flame.
She focused this power...
...to light a flame of her own...
...but she failed to control it.
The Flame of Chaos... engulfed Mother and my sisters...
...and molded them into deformed creatures."
"Below us lies the ruins of the legendary city of Izalith.
There, the Molten Giant watches over the Flame of Chaos.
Our Fair Lady, and Mistress Quelaag, fled from the ruins.
I do not know the details… and I do not ask…"
When the Witch of Izalith attempted to create the First Flame
something went wrong.
She created a Bed of Life, which would become the source of all demons.
There were originally seven daughters of Chaos.
The Witch and two sisters were bound to the Bed of Chaos.
The Witch is trapped inside
and her two sisters became the orbs beside her.
Quelaag and The Fair Lady were bound to giant spiders.
One sister was corrupted... and guards her mother.
Another sister was sacrificed and is watched by her brother,
who became the being of Ceaseless Discharge.
Only Quelana remains.
"And now I am here.
But my mother and sisters have been in anguish since.
I beseech you...
Free Mother and my sisters from the Flame of Chaos. I cannot do it myself.
I lack the strength...
...and the bravery…
But you…
I realize what I am asking.
But please...
...free their poor souls…
Quelaag, the deformed daughter of Izalith,
she escaped with her sister, and they fashioned the home at a base of Blight town.
The denizens of Blight town were chosen as servants and food.
But The Fair Lady felt for the suffering of her disfigured followers
and sucked out their blight pus.
She poisoned herself.
"I'm so sorry, dear sister."
And so the Fair Lady started to die.
But at least she has her sister Quelaag.
"But promise me…
...that you will take care of yourself."
Quelaag kills everyone who enters her lair
to gather the humanity that heals her dying sister.
That is until she is killed by the Chosen Undead.
So, who will take care of her now that her sister is gone?
Queelag? Please, sister, do not cry.
I am happy, really.
I have you...
...don't I?"
Darkwraith Kirk, Knight of Thorns has tricked Darkstalker Kaathe out of a Red Eye Orb.
He invades worlds to steal humanity to heal the Fair Lady, rather than give them to Kaathe.
His actions reveal that not all darkwraiths are evil.
However, he is ultimately killed by the Chosen Undead
as his intentions are not understood until his corpse is found in the Fair Lady's company.
Time in Lordran is convoluted.
One undead may replace Quelaag out of guilt.
Another may choose to put The Fair Lady out of her misery.
"Quelaag… But...
...why?"
"Why... you monster!
The Fair lady! What have you done... What have you done?"